Okay Micheal, so I've erased the screen and kept Bellman's equation,
the most important equation ever and we are going to solve it.
>> Oh.
>> So, how are we going to make that work? Okay, so how many, so
we wrote this down as a utility of s, how many S's are there?
>> s, n, m, I don't know?
>> Pick a letter.
>> N.
>> N, so we N states which means this
isn't really one equasion. This is how many equations?
>> N.
>> Yes it's N equations. How many unknowns are there?
>> Well we have U, the Rs are known, the Ts are known, the only
things that's missing is the Us. And there's, oh and there's N of those as well.
>> Right there's N equation in N [UNKNOWN].
>> So we're done. Yes because we know
how to solve n equations in n unknowns, right?
>> If the equations were linear.
>> If the equations were linear. Are these equations linear?
>> I'm going to go with no.
>> Why not?
>> because the max is problematic.
>> That's right. This max operation makes it nonlinear.
So, it looks really good for a moment there. We've
got n equations, n unknowns. We know how to solve
that. But max makes for a very very very weird
non linearity. And there's kind of no nice way
to deal with this. Actually, one day, Michael, if you
ask me, there is a cute little aside you can
do where you can turn max into something that's differentiable.
>> Oh.
>> But. That
doesn't actually help us here so I'm not going to go off on that aside yet.
>> But even differentiable wouldn't quite be linear.
>> That's right. And it wouldn't help us in
this case. Yeah that's exactly right. But the fact that
you can have differentiable maxes I think actually [UNKNOWN].
But also unimportant for what we're talking about now. So,
we've got n equations, n unknowns, they're nonlinear, which
means we can't solve it the way we want to
by like inverting matrices or like. You people are in
the regression would normally do but it turns out that
we can in fact, do something fairly
similar, something that actually allows us to
solve this even though it is nonlinear.
And here's the equation, or the equation,
here's, here's the algorithm you use that sort of works, okay? So it's really
simple. Just simply start with some arbitrary
utilities. Declare those the answer and you're done.
>> That would be one way of doing it but it turns out we can do even better.
>> Wait. Start off with the correct utilities.
>> That
would work except we don't know what they are.
>> Oh right.
>> So we're going to start with some arbitrary
utilities, but then we're going to update them based on
their neighbors. And then we'll simply lather, rinse, repeat.
Alright, so what does that mean based on neighbors?
>> So, it means, based on the states, you're going to update
the utility for a state based on all of the states that
it can reach. So, let me write down an equation that tells
you how to update them and then maybe it'll be clear, okay?
>> Yep.
>> So we're going to have a bunch of
utilities since we're going to, we're going to be looping
through this. And let's just say every time
we loop through, that's time t. Okay? So we
know what the equation for utility is where the utilities are. It's just the
equation that's written up here. So it's r of s plus gamma
times the mass over a of. The expected
utility. Right? Except we have some estimate of the utility
at time t. Okay? and, probably the right thing for me
to do would be to write this like as you
had or something like that. This is my estimate of the
utility. And so now using this, I'm going to want to sort
of update the, you know all of my utilities to make
them better. And it turns out I can do that
by simply doing this. So I'm going to update at every iteration
update utilities based on neighbors I'm going to
update at every iteration, at every iteration my
estimate of the utility of some state S by simply recalculating it to be the
actual reward that I get for entering
state S, plus the discounted utility that I
expect given the original estimates of my
utility. Does that make any sense at all?
>> Yeah, I guess so, so. So the s, okay, so, so we
need the whole u hat t.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Like at all states, because we're not just using the
values that state s to update the values that state s.
We're using all the values, at the, at the previous time
step to update all the values to the current time step.
>> Yep.
>> So, so all these n equations, they're all tangled together.
>> Right, because of this This, expectation. So really, just to
make it clear, this should be a summation over s prime.